COULD BE BURNED DOWN RIGHT NOW.
>> SADLY, THEY WERE A SIMILAR
ANTIPOLICE PROPOSALS INCLUDING A
NEW YORK CITY COUNCIL CANDIDATE.
IN THAT CASE, 40 OR SO OF THEM.
THEY RECLINED THIS FORMER
SPOKESPERSON ALSO CALLING FOR
POLICE TO BE DEFUNDED.
SO TWEETING "I JUST WANT US TO
DIG DEEPER THAT THE HASHTAG
DEFUND POLICE MOVEMENT ISN’T
JUST BRUSHED ASIDE."
THE MOB, THE MEDIA, SOME THEY
ARE PUSHING FOR THE POLICE TO BE
ABOLISHED.
A NEW STORY IN THE ATLANTIC
READS "DEFUND THE POLICE.
AMERICAN IS TO RETHINK ITS
PRIORITIES FOR THE WHOLE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
TO GET RID OF SENTENCING.
ROLLING STONE PUBLISHING,
PRACTICAL GUIDE FOR DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE WILL MAKE
US SAFER.
REALLY?
AND LOOK AT THIS.
AND A RARE MOMENT OF COMMON
SENSE FROM THE MEDIA MOB, YOU
HAVE A WRITER OVER AT FOX.COM
TWEETING "I’M SORRY, BUT THIS
ABOLISHED THE POLICE SEEMS LIKE
A POORLY THOUGHT OUT IDEA THAT
HAS GOTTEN POPULAR WITH SHOCKING
SPEED.
AFTER WIDESPREAD RAGE AND
CONDEMNATION FROM HIS FAR LEFT
PEERS, GUESS WHAT?
HE WAS PRESSURED, GROUPTHINK,
FORCED TO APOLOGIZE.
SO CLEARLY IN THE NEW RADICAL
FAR LEFT SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, IT IS NOW OFFICIALLY WOKE
TO ABOLISH THE POLICE.
TODAY, HE BROUGHT UP A REALLY
GOOD POINT IN HIS TWEET WRITING
"MAYBE IT’S TIME FOR SOME
ENTERPRISING BLUE STATE
MUNICIPALITY TO TO GO AND ELIMIN
ITS POLICE FORCE.
LET’S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
HOW ABOUT WE WILL START WITH
YOU.
HOW ABOUT YOU GIVE UP THE ENTIRE
POLICE DEPARTMENT IN NEW YORK,
GIVE TWO WEEKS PAID LEAVE,
INCLUDING THE ARMED POLICE
OFFICERS PROTECTING YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY EVERY DAY AND AFTER ALL,
BLACK LIVES MATTER HAVE ALREADY
PROMISED THEY ARE GOING TO FILL
THE VOID.
AND THEY WILL PATROL THE STREETS
FORMED, MALICIOUS IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IT, ARMED PEACE OFFICERS,
THE SAME GROUP THAT FREQUENTLY
IS CALLED FOR VIOLENCE AGAINST
THE POLICE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> PIGS IN A BLANKET.
I AM LIKEFRY THEM LIKE BACON.
>> WHY DO WE?
>> DEAD COPS.
>> WHEN DO WE WANT THEM?
>> NOW.
>> Sean: DIDN’T HE MEET WITH
SOME OF THE RADICALS IN SOME OF
THESE GROUPS?
AS YOU ARE WATCHING TONIGHT, ASK
YOURSELF THIS QUESTION, HOW DO
YOU FEEL?
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH POLICE
BEING REPLACED BY BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND OTHERS?
ACCORDING TO GALLUP, WE HAVE
THAT ANSWER, A RESOUNDING NO.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
TRUST THE POLICE.
IN FACT, ACCORDING TO GALLUP,
ONLY THE POLICE, THE MILITARY,
SMALL BUSINESSES RECEIVE A NET
POSITIVE AND JUST FOR THE RECORD
RECORD, THE POLITICIANS HAD THE
HIGHEST NET NEGATIVE RATINGS.
SOME FAR LEFT MAYORS, GOVERNORS,
WILLING TO DISMANTLE THE POLICE.
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE, THE
MICHIGAN GOVERNOR,
GOVERNOR SHUTDOWN SAYS THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE SENTIMENT BEHIND
THE MOVEMENT AND THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR SHUTDOWN USE THE POLICE
TO ENFORCE OVER THE TOP
ABSOLUTELY OBSCENE, LOCKDOWN
OWNERS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SOCIAL DISTANCING ORDERS, TOOK
POINT IN A PROTEST.
IN FOR SHUTDOWN, MANY OTHER
DEMOCRATS THE RULES DON’T APPLY
TO THEM.
IF YOU ARE HAVING A FUNERAL EVEN
THOUGH YOU WEAR A MASK IN
NEW YORK, THEN THEY WILL
PARTICIPATE IN PROTESTS WITH
ZERO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THEY WILL DISBAND THE POLICE
FORCE ALL WHILE THEY REMAIN SAFE
AND SOUND.
OF COURSE, THEY HAVE THEIR ARMED
GUARDS AND THEIR HIGH WALL
SECURITY.
LET BUSINESSES GET LOOTED,
BURNED TO THE GROUND ALL WHILE
CONTINUING TO TAKE THEIR
PAYCHECK.
WE NEED PROXY VOTING AND MAIL-IN
BALLOTS FOR PEOPLE’S HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
SO MUCH IS ON THE LINE.
MUST ALL DO IT BY MAIL.
IT’S GOING TO COME DOWN TO ONE